two people that are listening right now
did a large transaction with somebody
and after that transaction have never
interacted with that person ever again
mm-hmm I believe that and that's why I
just resonated with all of you
right you've got your prospective so on
welcome everybody to the mortgage
marketing expert podcast we are a proud
founding member of the industry
syndicate our mortgage marketing expert
today is none other than the man Gary
Vaynerchuk and I appreciate you so much
for having us here I appreciate that
it's been been a long time coming
obviously agent 2021 and it finally got
to make this happen our audience is in
large part mortgage professionals some
real estate professionals and a lot of
that audience is starting to consume
your content but not all of them have
have seen you yet so really what I want
to do to add value to them most value
that I can add is time I want to kind of
curate some of content that I may know
the answers to or some of them just kind
of put it in one place happy to do it
so the average age of originator is late
40s early 50s that group of people
didn't grow up with social media didn't
necessarily do the mortgage industry
that way so as far as focusing on
personal branding like what advice do
you have to that group of people that
doesn't find this kind of thing all that
natural I think that that group
understands reputation the amount of 40
to 50 year olds that dominate in
mortgage and real estate on a hundred
percent model of word-of-mouth
reputation of the work they put in for
the last 20 years is very high and when
I hear the word personal brand and when
a lot of people hear the word personal
brand they think it's a douchey term
like they think there's a stigma to that
term yet when I hear it I just hear the
word reputation and ironically 49 year
old Donny who thinks you know personal
brand is doof [ __ ] of like 22 year olds
when he or she hears
up you know reputation they take a
totally different point of view on it so
just to set the tone right away the
reason to make content on LinkedIn on
Facebook
on these platforms is to build scaled
reputation what you think it's
impossible that you put out a video on
LinkedIn that give somebody a smart
tidbit that's seen by somebody in
Alabama who happens to be the sister of
somebody that's in your residential area
who says have you know do you know this
guy do you know this girl and then that
leads to your lead gen to close a deal
like just so everybody knows who doesn't
know me or or knows me but doesn't
understand I'm out here talking about
things that drive business results like
you know I happen to believe they come
from things like providing value and
understanding where the customers
attention is the same reason your
grandpappy called your firm triple a
mortgage is because he understood that
the Yellow Pages had all the attention
and if you named your company triple a
mortgage you showed up first and more
people called the first number in the
yellow pages all I'm doing is that same
move on LinkedIn and Facebook I love
that what about those people that say
don't we can end this podcast right now
if we absolutely could you know you know
I mean it though like you know if you're
a logical unemotional nandi manizer of
technology and are willing to be
self-aware enough that you just actually
don't want to put in the work not that
you don't think it actually works and
you heard what I just said for the last
three minutes this is a wrap yeah this
is a very basic model of something that
is historically true as far back as you
somebody drew the best pictures in caves
somebody had the best forearms to do the
most smoke signals on the top of a
[ __ ] mountain it's like like like
somebody was born with the gift of a
voice that was the right one to read a
radio ad in 1937 I'm not doing anything
new I'm just doing it best in the thing
that is right now to sell mortgages to
sell homes to sell b2b shopping
complexes selling it out to sell
sneakers and wine to change people's
opinions on
what an alpha male should be to talk
about modern parenting vulnerabilities
to pontificate about my dear love of the
New York Jets and everything else that
comes through my [ __ ] mind but this
is contextual communications at scale
for the world we actually live in not
the one that you built your career on
for example how can your picture on a
bench bus ad be that worth the same when
every single passenger on earth now is
looking at their phone when they're
driving by theory it should be 35% less
in cost by just common sense you should
be paying 35% less for your bench ad
today than you did eight years ago
because now 100 percent of passengers
are looking at their phone drivers not
even looking at the road truth no I
that's stuff like that and now while
you're listening and you're yelling or
thinking in your mind
yeah Gary but my direct mail works am i
cool Sally but if you spent that same 11
thousand dollars on Facebook properly
I'll get you more leads you know why
because I still do direct mail for my
dad's liquor store in New Jersey and I
run them against swipe up ads on
Instagram I know the math I'm not
pontificating off of theory every person
right now who's listening who says this
stuff doesn't work isn't actually doing
it or they did it once for 500 bucks on
Facebook they put out a piece of [ __ ] ad
it didn't work and they decided it was
Facebook's fault
that's like me blaming a basketball for
not being LeBron like that one it's true
it's a better way to say the thing I
usually say I like that clip that [ __ ]
Dustin well one of the first pieces of
content that I you know several years
ago really made the connection with this
guy Gary Vee was you were talking about
boards of directors and leadership's
within companies that have been doing it
one way for 30 years and are on their
way out and don't necessarily have the
motivation to learn a new skill set or
to put a lot of dollars and cents to it
and that's been very much the mortgage
industry for the last few years they've
used excuses of compliance or
or whatever else yeah and so the people
that are having challenges with their
companies and leadership to think like
that ironically though if I apologize
rocket mortgage and zebra and all these
other people are not struggling with
those same issues and oh by the way
let's talk about the elephant in room
are [ __ ] dominating right why are we
having this conversation agreed this is
like literally the conversations I'm
having with network television debating
that OTT doesn't work do you live in
life do you understand not one person
doesn't watch Netflix or Hulu and by the
way that's without Warner Disney X just
came out apples just coming out peacocks
coming from MBC [ __ ] we haven't even
started wait - I dropped vein or OTT I'm
gonna take a million subscriptions
absolutely you're never gonna see this
content again for free I'm kidding I'm
kidding
not really but yes that's good stuff so
being a loan officer is a lot like you
talking about being a business owner
being a firefighter that's a huge
challenge in a lot of sales marketing
entrepreneur type things what are what
are some tips you can give folks as far
as wearing that firefighter hat and
still effectively building their
business well being a firefighter is the
business great distinction you know like
if you're interested in living a life
that you want what comes the great do
you not fun it is to be my employees
they they can blame me like you know fun
it is to blame Andy when he it's
somebody above you like well his concept
is stupid that's why it's not working
and then they're like wait a minute but
actually Gary took it's Gary's fault
it's so fun to be an employee it's super
not fun to be you know everything is
actually your fault if there's like a
leak in my office and Long Island cyber
last year like them okay
like when they heat doesn't work or when
I change my strategy on the snacks we're
using and everyone decides I'm the worst
human ever or whatever it is like
everything is my fault everything is my
fault
but that's what I chose to do if you
want the [ __ ] accolades
you gotta eat the [ __ ] that comes along
with it and the more [ __ ] you can eat
the more likely the accolades get bigger
it's so good it's so so if you don't
want the fires be an employee and enjoy
yourself I love that like it's but
that's what it is it's about making
choices and dealing with the rampa gate
how can you possibly get the glory
without the work like how is that
possible
like with why have people thought that's
there how how have we gotten into a
place where people believe that you can
be successful without bleeding and
bleeding comes in a lot of forms some
people it's 15 hours a day some people
it's nine hours a day but nine highly
stress you know to me it's less about
hours it's more about stomach what can
your stomach handle can you deal with
the scrutiny you know how not fun it is
to be me in a world where I hate being
disliked and every day thousands of
people are actively putting out the
information to say they dislike me
unsocial that requires a stomach as
opposed to being grateful that people
are actually look at you in the first
place
yeah but by the way I'm not a buyer of
all policies good publicity when
somebody thinks I'm a charlatan or a
snake oil salesman I don't like that
mention like right like like all the
weirdness is not equal like like it's
ludicrous that all publicity is good
publicity really just not interested
like I don't want no that's not true
right you know so what's your take on
mortgage real estate the the industry as
a whole you had a really cool
perspective at agent 2021 about the
direction the industry is heading I'd
love for you to kind of expand on that
share I think the internet eats up
everything and if you do not know how
and I do not think it eliminates
everybody who has a job I think it
eliminates people who do not bring value
and what I said at age of 22 when I mean
which is if I started a veiner brokerage
right now I would win because people
want to build a personal brands not pay
higher if I come out with lower fees
than the market and offer the ability to
build up your personal brand along the
way how am I not gonna kill everybody
you will yeah I'm probably not gonna do
it because I'm super not interested in
it but but somebody else is going to and
it's about providing value this is one
became a value the reason I will always
win is I inherently know that I'm only
interested in providing value to the
customer and everything else is
secondary
that's so awesome and I think it's
important the feedback that you get from
your consumer I was recently listened to
when your podcast where you're talking
about the consumer is who you listen to
you're not you don't pay attention to
anybody else's content you're just
observing the consumer and consumer
behavior and that drives your actions if
you think I've done the homework to know
that these upstart mortgage companies
are doing well because I've actually
done the homework you're out of your
mind I know it because I read comments I
know what people talk about it's the
same same reason I know who the baby is
and the same reason I know every single
five star quarterback who's [ __ ] 12
right now and the same reason I know
which that tick-tock is on its verge of
going mainstream
it's all the same game so why my
contents good I know what to talk about
because I know what people are
interested in I'm good because I listen
everybody thinks I just talk because I
interrupt I talk all the time to produce
so much content that's the manifestation
of the better listening it's why I
always have ideas others have ideas
because I'm a perpetual listening is
easy to have ideas when you're listening
you don't even have ideas you're just
fulfilling needs so do you think you
think I wanted to talk about parenting I
didn't even cross my [ __ ] mind
it's just getting a billion [ __ ] DMS
they're like but my mom this and my mom
that and my dad this and like oh [ __ ]
right that's why you're not posting
that's why you're not doing what you
want your dad told you have to be a
lawyer and you don't know how to think
any other way especially because you and
then they play then you start playing
chess not checkers oh right it's not
because your dad [ __ ] put you into
some weird coma it's that you still want
dad to pay for your stuff
you value your equinox and uber and
[ __ ] easy so much that you're willing
to live a life that doesn't make you
happy so you're still on the payroll and
what dad wants is for you to be a lawyer
now I understand and that's how I
laminate right absolutely so to drill
down on that for real estate and
mortgage professionals specifically if
they're you know have a couple hundred
followers and they're they're commenting
and reading what are they need to be
paying attention to what should they
focus on underscores that that's small
of a scale anything they get which is
not gonna be a whole lot it's probably
like your aunt saying go Rick you know
so you're not gonna get [ __ ] from that
what you probably want to do is consume
other people's content you probably want
to go into five to 15 meaningful
Facebook groups that talked about this
you make you definitely want to look
join your local community do you know
any people built their entire business
on being part of the local Chamber of
Commerce but refuse to get a Facebook
account and join a Facebook group about
the town you know [ __ ] stupid that is
[Laughter]
you you're religious about the idea of
like doing all these community literally
ninety percent of people that are
listening right now are focused on doing
community tactics I'm gonna sponsor the
softball team I'm gonna walk the [ __ ] in
parade I'm gonna I'm gonna join the PTA
I'm gonna [ __ ] join the Chamber of
Commerce I'm gonna start the Small
Business Alliance I'm gonna walk for
[ __ ] nine hours down Main Street to
all 13 stores eight times all for the
ability to hand their business card to
somebody with the hope that they use
them versus what I would do which is I'm
gonna watch TV lay in my [ __ ]
underwear open my phone be in the
community [ __ ] page on Facebook join
the community and talk about the high
school football team or Karen or the
[ __ ] pothole on Main Street and get
four times more to the [ __ ] business
than your [ __ ] idiotic waste of 8,000
[ __ ] hours in the local community
[ __ ] what are we talking about here
there's the blueprint everyone there you
go I just gave it to you do that join
the Facebook groups that are local to
your town go in there and don't be a
spam bot and just say use me use me
actually be a normal citizen like I just
painted you were by doing all those
lovely things you do you understand that
but you didn't you refuse to do what I
just told you
which would triple your business and
give you a lot more time to do stuff you
want because I think a lot of you were
hustling and you don't want to actually
go to the town leave the Main Street
[ __ ] open you know Small Business
Saturday weekend and you'd actually
rather go play soccer with your kid
you'd rather go on a date with your
husband but that's how you actually do
business because you refuse to realize
it's 2020 that's my life that's what I
think about love it I think there's so
many people that needed to hear that and
I appreciate you sharing that because
there's you get the same old answers is
what content do I create when do I have
time to create it what do I talk about
what's the audience that every single
person listening here right now wastes
40% of their time on dump [ __ ] what when
when you're not sitting in your office
waiting for the phone to ring how about
then how many great content then hell
are you doing yep
you've put busy work on a pedestal not
results-driven work just because you
work 11 hours a day cool you can waste
11 hours in a heartbeat not to mention
if you actually audit it you actually
spent 72 minutes watching my content you
actually spent 15 minutes going back and
forth with your friend on texts debating
tonight's Thursday night game you like
like I'm actually working like my teen
stress when I'm like one minute off on
something that's actually real life yeah
like we're [ __ ] scrambling you should
see my poor admins out there their mess
who walked in no like easy starting
right now
you know like need 30 seconds it's
literally every minute so I know what
the extreme is and I don't recommend
after everybody that just you found your
perfect I found my crescendo I found my
[ __ ] perfect spot where are my
talents meet my happiness not everyone's
gonna do that but don't tell me you
don't have time so I want to talk about
that for a minute because one of my
coaches talks about our ROI versus our
we return on energy and we're that
geniuses is finding things that are ry
positive
but also feed you energy that's kind of
the space that you live in I like the
way that person framed it yes I
understand that because it also is a
perpetual and machine if you're happy
it's gonna make you want to work more
you know I'm put out a post yesterday or
a couple days ago that really resonated
it's the first time I said I said I
actually don't think anyone's lazy I
don't think you're lazy I think you're
showing yourself that you don't like it
and I know what that looks like it's why
I have a terrible report card like I
know exactly what not wanting to do
something manifests in poor results so
another direction I wanna kind of go in
is sales versus marketing marketing is
getting someone's attention sales is
actually closing the deal making them a
customer what would what is your take on
that whole concept I spend 90% of my
energy on marketing and everybody thinks
they're marketing and they're spending a
hundred percent of time on sales are you
finding that most sales industries are
lazy compared to what they were you know
to know here's our basic I think their
basic they think the sale is that that's
the religion it's the number right now
and they're not thoughtful they don't
understand the expense of it I
understand that when I sent a second
text for wine text that a lot of people
gonna unsubscribe but I made more sales
so yeah I got 360 more bottles but at
what cost
I just lost 44 people that will never
buy people don't think people think in
cat customer acquisition costs they
don't think in LTV do young people that
are listening right now did a large
transaction with somebody and after that
transaction have never interacted with
that person ever again mm-hmm I believe
that and that's why I just resonated
with all of you right mm-hmm
why don't you send somebody a $23
[ __ ] [ __ ] fruit basket with a nice
card that maybe references some in a
moment during your interactions when you
saw the pretty bird or you spilled
coffee on yourself to show them you
actually are a human which then will
actually lead to like maybe them
referring you to somebody else you're
spending all your time hunting for the
other thing yet now that you got through
Commission and you signed them up
or you sold in the house you never talk
to them again that is 98% of the
behavior of 98% of the agents so good
right it is listen why don't you have a
basic system that sends somebody a nice
gift with a handwritten card cuz the
gifts easy and then eventually doesn't
feel human with a handwritten card on
the one-year anniversary of the closing
of your deal that happens to be the time
where I might just have dinner with
friends that night and say somebody sent
me a jet spy today that I didn't my
[ __ ] brokerage deal with it like oh
you actually were in the market for we
we need mortgage we need to refinance
i'ma go you have to go with Don
he sends [ __ ] jet spies knowing but
no everybody wants a cold call or direct
mail or [ __ ] I'm so [ __ ] well and
that's one of the reasons the level of
disrespect I have for the other person
that's listening to this podcast right
now is enormous Lehigh and don't let
disrespect come across mean it's just
that I'm just so passionate to get
people to do new [ __ ] get out of our
comfort zone somebody's about to take
your lunch what I love so much your
content is about understanding and
paying attention to the most basic of
human behaviors correct and
understanding what it's about you know
we talk about effective marketing is the
balance of trust and attention you guys
good enough just to be out there
blasting yourself all over social media
and and Trust is an interesting word
because I think it leads to behavior
that's a little one-dimensional I think
its relevance relevance right so like
trust can hurt people because I believe
when you say that people on the other
side then start with over selling
themselves to provide trust got it you
see where I'm going absolutely I'm think
about Karen right now who hears this
she's motivated she's like [ __ ] it I'm
making my first LinkedIn video and she
is Trust which makes sense and I don't
think meditation I'm sort of learned
that words matter more than I've thought
you know people are pretty semantical uh
when I hear trust as Karen who just got
motivated finally because I'm putting
pressure on the system and she's gonna
make her LinkedIn video she here's trust
and she's gonna start with a heavy sell
upfront I've been doing this for 23
years right
whereas meanwhile the way that Karen
would have gotten my business is by
making a reference to the Jets game
against the Eagles this weekend because
that's relevance or you know absolutely
or being an immigrant absolutely or
liking root beer this is why I push
people to show every part of their lives
you never know if it's heavy metal right
or or it's growing up with you know
immigrant parents right or or sports
culture right like you don't know what
the relevance is but there's always
relevance for sure and and the number
one advantage everybody has on the other
side of this is the most unique thing
about you is you it is peeing your pants
in second grade a story I shared it is
you know the way I became a Jets fan
because I needed something to latch on
to America something I shared my report
card something you know many people
follow me cuz they sucked in high school
too you know late able it's yes it's
relevant relevance and it's true yep you
know I like hip-hop music I like
football I notice how little I talk
about [ __ ] video games I [ __ ] am
very aware that video game culture is a
great content pillar for me to play on
but I have to share when I do I have to
share that I can beat everybody in ice
hockey for Nintendo because that's the
last time I was a gangster in video
games with 19 [ __ ] hater 7c I don't
talk about for night I talk about the
culture fortnight so you stay in your
lane you stay around your passions and
you build a community around interests
love it and then when you're localized
around that interests you put out a
LinkedIn piece of content around Zelda
you sell mortgages in [ __ ] Des Moines
Iowa and you find yourself eight weeks
later in a coffee shop with eleven
people all dressed up as [ __ ] link
and peach and and four days later you
closed your biggest deal that's way
better than a direct mail piece or a
cold call or [ __ ] passionately here's
why it's better cuz you have fun when
you [ __ ] dressed up as a mushroom
[Laughter]
so I want to be a good steward of your
time I want to ask one last question at
which we ask all of our guests is talked
about a lot of stuff yep but if you
could just give one tip to mortgage
professionals today to go out to use to
build their business what would it be
stop being audacious your industry is
audacious bunch of people wearing suits
thinking they know something that's my
advice
cut the audacity everybody smart knows
you're [ __ ] lost get your [ __ ]
together it's time that's if you do not
produce content for YouTube LinkedIn and
Facebook every day as a real estate and
Instagram as a real estate or mortgage
professional you're losing figure it out
that's a big statement I know that
sounds scary you haven't posted anything
I'm asking you for [ __ ] platforms a
day go Google go learn how do I post on
YouTube I'm giving you the statement
there I don't need to give you tactics
my friends it's called Google Google and
you don't know how to make a video
Google I don't even know what Final Cut
Pro is I could figure everything they
all do I can do it a day it's called
Google actually for me it's YouTube I
can't read for [ __ ] I'd have to watch it
but I know keep yourself at god I hate
[ __ ] I hate people that talk
something they don't live plenty of
leaders talking about keep learning
every day yet refuse to [ __ ] learn
before I think we started the podcast
because I don't think we members here we
talked about your daughter you know
knowing who I am I'm living my truth I
tell you to keep doing it I keep doing
it I've got a million followers on
tik-tok that's not [ __ ] bragging
about my following on Tic Tac that's me
living my [ __ ] truth take that didn't
cross my mind On January 1st
well the reason is so cool from my
perspective but is his legacy it wasn't
ready my daughters were able to consume
some of the content that I consume
language and all and then on their
platform that was native to them they
now appreciate who you are and consume
your content on a completely different
level because to your point the
relevance
tik-tok is relevant to them that's the
content that they consume correct
you're so good and that's why I can go
outside and have a nine-year-old ask for
a selfie and an 84 year old and that is
incredible incredible and I'm grateful
and I want to and I think for everybody
if you've stayed long enough of iron
just made you stop listening with my
energy all that energy all that pressure
all that cursing I just did that is a
plea for you to be happy - I could care
less if you do it or not as a matter
fact for the record the number one great
thing in the short term for me that
could happen is nobody listens to
anything I talk about because it's only
one stream and we're all vying for the
same attention you're trying to sell
home I'm trying to get people to sign up
for wine text by the way wine techs comm
sign up low I'll be in the show notes as
well just in case you missed that I
appreciate that
all right we appreciate you thanks so
much great thank you so much
you